[Musique]
c'est quoi tout ça m'a rien on fête un
anniversaire
juste un petit 10 des ports 10 13
couvert qui a fait ça pendant ma invités
évidemment il n'a rien dit c'est bien
mais ça pas question d'être très à table
ça porte malheur
il me faut une femme de plus ou moins à
madame je suis la bonne ne dira pas que
vous êtes là bora je ne sais pas mentir
ne s'était pas ça va aller toutes les
femmes ça vous retire il suffit de
sourire comme ça vous allait briller
david mort car on n'arrive pas de nom de
famille non pas ce soir
vous résolvez harry guen ne lui fait pas
trop
ah les émois faire c'est pour que les
dames s'occupent de moi que j'adore
l'asperger d'eau y est j'ai un cadeau
pour toi c'est le bordel il se voit baup
on dirait un épouvantable accident grave
incident qui serait tombé amoureux
d'elle c'est possible admet le à la cud
en fait j'ai pu faire mes mails et à ces
gens c'est pas possible
c'était pas votre monde vous jouer dans
la cour des grands
il est même madame elle me transporte
et je crois qu'on devrait tout hirata
fit certainement pas j'ai besoin de cet
argent
je sentais quelque chose quand il m'a
regardé ce que vous avez senti c'est
surtout libre s et se femme pas en bonne
qui vaut tant que matin
[Musique]
ginette même désir
être un os
[Musique]